-Kathryn, you are
an incredible actor,
which means you're in touch with
many different emotions,
so I want to see just how
emotional we can get.
It's time for
an Emotional Interview.
-♪ Emotional Interview ♪
-Now, here's how it works.
We'll have a normal conversation
with each other,
except every so often,
we're going to hear
this ding sound...
[ Ding ]
And when we hear that, we'll be
given an emotion or a situation
that we have to act out
as we keep talking.
Sound okay?
-Yes.
-Alright, good.
Here we go.
Let's just -- I'll start off
the conversation.
Do you have any
big summer plans, maybe?
-Oh, yes.
[ Ding ]
Huge ones. I --
-Oh, that sounds great!
Ooh, it's going to be so good.
-Right?!
I love the beach, and I love
summer, and I love suntans.
-I love summer, sun, sun,
anything with an "S",
I love, love, love!
"S", "S", "S", "S"!
-Anything with an "S"
is up my alley!
-Anything with an "S" is --
-I'm with you.
And you know what?
You're the best, Jimmy.
-No!
-You're the best.
-Well, you're probably looking
in the mirror,
because you are the best.
[ Ding ]
That's what I'm talking about.
-[ Laughs ] You're going to make
me cry right now.
I am literally -- I don't know
what to tell you.
You know what's so relaxing?
Doing virtual interviews.
I love it. What I love about it
is technology,
'cause I'm so good at it.
-Oh, I was --
No, I was --
Sorry, I was, uh --
I was listening to
what you were saying.
-Oh. Oh, OK.
Well, you're such a good
listener, Jimmy,
and you're a really --
make it easy on your guests.
-You know, I -- Well, I was
thinking about, you know,
going to my -- because I live on
an island.
I have an island that I go to
with my wife.
She's from Canada.
You probably don't know her.
-You do?
[ Ding ]
-Yeah.
-And I'm --
-But, you know, hey,
it is what it is.
-Well, I hear you.
It is what it is.
-[ Laughs ]
-Hey, hey!
It is what it is.
-Yeah, that's --
Yeah, we -- Yeah, you know.
It is what it is.
-Hey, you know what's a great --
You know what's a great TV show?
"The Sopranos".
[ Imitating Tony Soprano ]
"Hey, it is what it is."
-No, no, no, no, no.
No, I love the movie
"GoodFellas", when he was like,
[ Italian accent]
"Hey, it is what it is."
-Oh, I know exactly.
When he's like this --
Oh! I heard...
What I heard...
about "GoodFellas".
-What?
-Let me tell you something.
-Give me the hot.
-Real scotch.
-Real scotch in those glasses in
"GoodFellas".
-Is that right?
-That wasn't just, you know...
-I heard --
-...The flavored iced tea.
They were -- They were loaded
the whole time.
That's what I heard.
-I heard they were --
-Don't tell anybody.
-I heard they were all
sleeping together.
-[ Gasps ]
-Joe Pesci and Robert De Niro.
-[ Laughs ]
-Pesci and De Niro?!
-I don't know.
-Ooh, Pesci.
-You know...
-Both: It is what it is.
[ Ding ]
[ Laughter ]
-I -- Oh.
-I got a new car.
-I heard you.
You told me.
-And it looks like the DeLorean.
-Oh, no, I -- My car talks to me
and tells me
that I should speed up
or slow down.
I love it. It's so fun.
-Listen, I don't like to brag
about my car,
being from L.A. and everything,
but let me tell you something,
the doors go like that
instead of like that.
-I put my -- My door has
facial recognition,
So I put --
And the door comes up,
hits me in the face,
and I go, "Life is great."
I just love it.
It's cool.
Everyone should get into it.
It's not that expensive.
It's only like, $300,000.
-You know what?
[ Ding ]
Oh!
♪ That's amazing news ♪
♪ About your... ♪
-♪ Tesla! ♪
-♪ That's amazing news ♪
[ Ding ]
There you have it.
That was an Emotional Interview
with Kathryn Hahn.
"WandaVision" is available
on Disney+.
It is what it is!
-It is what it is!
-I'll be right back with
John M. Chu.
Everyone come on back.